guardians this is the Nova Corps you
have to help us this is a priority one
distress call star-lord anos is here
destroyer of worlds big glowy gauntlet
wrinkly chin yeah I've heard of him time
to rock and roll
alright space cops I want a clean slate
for my whole crew rocket Gamora Groot
and Drax looks like death out there
business as usual huh here's a situation
we tracked Thanos to this creep planet
ah Kree they're a technologically
advanced species stronger body powerful
military I am Groot dad why don't you
relax you big wooden baby we're just
going deeper into the old creepy temple
to stop a literal murder Aizen machine
what's the worst that could happen
ahh so this is how I die
I was never your daughter not a
nanosecond and we all would have been
atomized
[Music]
guess they're scared of us of me in
particular but you are helping if we're
a family it's only because you made us
one the time has come
either stano's Falls what we do Wow
yeah no pressure
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm only gonna say this once today
let's go be heroes hmm what stop
whatever your mouth is doing
[Music]
you